You don't want, Frank Mir broke his
arm and he tried to keep fighting. Yes.
You too. Right? Yeah.
Yeah. I remember that.
Cause I remember the crowd was
booing like woo. I was like, guys,
you need to look at this. Yeah, no
that's a, that's a, that's, let me,
I will tell you about that because that
was a fun story cause like they um,
I hadn't really,
there was one of the first times I think
they trusted me with a championship and
uh, he, he, you know, the arm
broke. I heard it, I saw it. And uh,
I remember, you know, I learned a lot.
I learned a lot about my
job right then because I,
what I did is I backed off and I let
the doctor come in and examine him.
Cause like, you know, sometimes
when you're dealing with an expert,
you don't want to cloud the way
you're supposed to get out of the way.
Like you don't go to the mechanic
and tell them what to do. So I had,
my mind was thinking like
that about the doctor.
And so of course he comes in and she
doesn't know what she's, what she saw.
So he missed guides her and says,
I think he's worried about this.
And then she's like, hey, no, nothing's
wrong. And I was like, aw man.
In my mind I was thinking is it was,
it's been great being here but I'm
not going to be doing this anymore.
You know what I mean?
And then beautiful.
He made that switch already in
your it. I swear. I was like,
in my mind I was thinking that I was
thinking about how to get out of there and
when they start throwing stuff,
oh you know the military camp from,
if you remember, they were over there
wrestling with the Samoan security guards,
tried to get in there and just going
crazy and people are screaming.
That's another, there's
other, there's other breakout.
It was an awful one. Yeah. So that, I was
thinking about that and then uh, you know,
but then you found it,
you saved me.
Like I was thinking that my retribution
was going to be like some kid on the
Internet two weeks later.
Like I found out his arm was broken,
but you found the spot. And so then that
was watching the replay and I was like,
let's take a look at this. Hold on, hold
on. What's that on his arm? I'm like,
that's a broken arm. I got bomb is broken.
Look at that. Watch it one more time. Oh,
and I had the truck roll up on,
then I went into the octagon and I,
I remember saying immediately like, you
guys need to watch this. Like, here we go.
Let's play this. Here we
go. That's a broken arm.
So I'm gonna thank you for
that right there. Cause I,
my career path would've been different.
Well that was one of those things
where I felt an obligation to not just
interview the fighter, but to explain to
the entire crowd. Like, you gotta listen,
this is a no, it looked crazy. Look
crazy to me too. This is a broken arm.
Like this guy's fucked right
now. Three places. And Tim,
thank you afterwards for saving
his career because he said,
if you didn't stop that fight and that
became a compound fracture. Fuck man.
Horrible things happen when the
bone breaks through the skin. Yeah.
I saw it happened. I saw him
afterwards and I said, man,
did you know your arm was
broken? And he told me, he
goes, yeah, I know. What was it?
What was your plan?
Where are you trying to continue?
So I knew I had a minute before.
The pain really becomes crippling
here is and watch this part, right?
Snap right there.
I mean that is 100% a double double break.
Yeah.
Both parts of the both bones of the
forum snapped in half and it's an unusual
break because of where it is.
Yeah.
It just shows you how fucking strong
frank arm bars and how long the MD is.
Oh, it was also weird as hell.
His arm went back into place.
How young and muscular
I talked to the doctor.
They say that happens
sometimes with athletes.
The muscles just put it
right back. Yeah. Yeah.
Well he had a plate put in there forever.
It's still in there. Look at me young.
We're fresh face. Joe Rogan,
man, that was young. Frank looks,
it's crazy. He looks so lean and young,
and he's a big old giant dude. Now.